okay so how do we summon the memory
demon the memory demon is a greater
demon do not break the barn will be far
more powerful it was quite intense and
you know a lot of moving parts and was
actually very interesting the machinery
that they put together to create that
light effect so the memory demon is
coming out of this vortex you're
basically acting like with your
imagination because there is no demon
there so they created this swirling gel
with light in the center you know we
were all holding hands around the
swirling vortex and it was wind and
smoke and we were yelling so it really
feels like there's a lot of energy no
jace who's the character who's the
strongest you know gets taken into this
vortex filming that was a couple of
hours on a wire a lot of screaming and a
lot of keeping my core muscles very
tight to keep my body at the angle that
it needed to be because I had to kind of
rotate in and out of it so it was a
physically and emotionally very
challenging but it's that's what's life
without a challenge that's why I do what
I do I love doing that sort of stuff